Hello and welcome. I'm James Murphy.
In this video, we're going to learn how to programmatically traverse yourPython code from within Python itself.
Then we'll use that ability to help us writecustom checks for our code
to prevent us from making common errors and keep our code qualityhigh.
Basically, the goal is to write a custom plugin for flake8.
flake8 is what's calleda linter.
It runs on your source code and then tells you if there's anything wrong.
In this case,it didn't find anything wrong with the cool_module.
However, if we add an unused variable into ourfunction and then run the linter again, it'll complain.
Local variable x is assigned but neverused.
Linters can also warn you about stylistic or other code style things.
Like, in this case, it'stelling me that there's no newline at the end of the file.
A linter like flake8 already has a tonof really good rules built into it
and for those that you don't like you can just turn them off.
Butwhat can you do if you want to add your own rule?
Let's say, just for example purposes that, youwant to disallow local imports in functions.
There's nothing necessarily wrong withhaving an import inside a function.
But sometimes, these function level imports areused as a crutch to avoid cyclic dependency issues.
Basically, a local import might be hiding a deeperarchitectural issue and we just want to prevent that.
But then, we run into a kind of big issue.
If I asked you to find all the local imports in a module, how would you do it?
You may reachfor regular expressions and try to match sort of the form of what a local import looks like.
Buteven for this simple task of finding local imports,
trying to do it with a regular expression is goingto be an absolute nightmare.
The issue with trying to use a regular expression is that
text is notthe natural way that we think about Python code.
I don't think about these concepts in termsof the literal characters that make them up.
Instead, I think on a more abstract levelin terms of classes, functions, for-loops etc.
Well, the good news is that Python itself alsothinks this way and it can expose this data to you.
We can see this representationof the data using the ast module.
When I run ast on my cool_module, this is what itlooks like.
It shows me I have a module
whose body starts with a function definition of a functionnamed cool
with an argument named n and so on.
This is called an abstract syntaxtree.
And it's exactly the kind of data structure that we need in orderto analyze our Python source code.
Running the ast module on a source filewill print out the abstract syntax tree.
But we can also import ast from within ourown code and access that tree at runtime.
In this example, we read the code from the sourcemodule.
Then we pass it to the ast.parse() function
This gives us back an in-memory representation ofthe tree.
Printing out the node that we get, we see the top level module object.
All these ast objectshave an underscore fields attribute.
So, you can see what things are inside of them.
You can alsofind this in the docs for the ast module.
So, we see a module has a body field.
Printingthat out, we see the body is made of a list of statements, in this case, just one functiondefinition.
We can dig further and further and get things like the name, argumentsor body of the function definition.
Everything that you see in this printout ofthe ast, we can actually now access from runtime.
So, I start with the top level node objectand then I could say node.body get the zeroth element
that says function definition and thendot name if I wanted to see what the name was.
So, this is great.
This tree like structureis now what allows us to traverse our Python code
in terms of Python constructsrather than literal characters.
ast also provides this NodeVisitorclass that we're meant to derive from.
A node visitor makes it really easy for us to walkthrough the entire tree and visit all of the nodes.
So here, we call visit on the root node
and whatvisit is going to do is, we'll just print out the node
and then we call this generic_visit whichwill visit all of the children of this node.
Here's the output.
You can see it starts with themodule then goes into the function definition.
And basically, we get a single call for every singlenode in the tree.
But normally, when you're linting your code and you have a specific rule in mind,
it doesn't just apply to every kind of object.
It doesn't apply to modules and classes andfunctions.
Maybe, I have a rule about a common error involving for-loops.
In that case, insteadof visiting everything, I can just say visit_For.
Now, when I run the code, I only get two callsbecause there were only two for-loops in the cool_module.
You can look it up in the ast docs for whatall these names are.
But basically, there's one for every single possible Python construct.
Okay, backto the goal. I want to warn if there's any import inside of a function.
I'm confident that if Icould get flake8 to call my code,
then I would be able to find all the local imports.
So, how do I getflake8 to call my code?
It's actually surprisingly simple.
I'll make a class for my plugin and thengive it a name and version.
This name and version are required and they're going to show up in thehelp text.
Then make an init function that takes an argument named tree.
flake8 will inspectthe signature and know to pass the ast here.
flake8 will construct my plugin and then call run.
And run is supposed to yield any errors that it finds.
Here, I just want to see it run. So, I'm justyielding nothing.
Then we create this dot flake8 configuration file in order to tell flake8 whereour plugin is.
It uses a standard ini file format.
Create this block for local-plugins andthen we're going to be creating an extension.
You could tell it about multiple extensionslike this. But for now, let's just stick to one.
On the left side, you tell it what code prefix allof your errors are going to use.
In this case, I'm using, like, mcoding 1.
So, I'm saying that allof my errors are going to start with MCOD1,
so like, MCOD100, MCOD101 and so on.
Then onthe right hand side, use the dotted path to the module. In this case, the module is just in the samedirectory.
And then, a colon followed by the name of the class.
Since my module is not in an installedpackage in the current virtual environment,
I just need to tell flake8 using this paths equalscurrent directory
to look in the current directory for plugins.
Otherwise, it's going to complainthat it can't find the flake8_mcoding module
And if we go ahead and run flake8 on our cool_module,
we see the running text that we printed out from the plugin.
Okay, our plugin is running but itcurrently doesn't do anything.
It just yields no errors. So, how do we yield an error?
flake8 expects you to yield errors as 4 tuples
including the line_number, the column offset,the message of the error and the class.
The line number_column and message are prettyself-explanatory. So, what's this class thing?
Well, it's actually not used for anythingat all. It's just completely ignored.
But it does have to be there and I generallyjust return the class that generated the error.
Just to see if everything's working,
we'll justtry always yielding an error, say, at line one at offset zero.
Running flake8 on thecool_module, we now see our custom error.
Note that, your error messages must start with theprefix that you specified in the configuration file, or they'll be ignored.
The prefix I specifiedwas MCOD1.
If I change that to a MCOD2 and run it again, then I no longer see the error.
Let's changeit back. But that's just something to be aware of.
Getting back to the goal of finding imports insideof functions, let's make a NodeVisitor and try to find them.
My NodeVisitor initializes an emptylist of errors and will populate that whenever it finds an import inside of a function.
We'll usevisit_FunctionDef to find all the function nodes.
Starting from a function definition node, finding alocal import is pretty easy.
We just loop over all the children in the body of the function.
Then ifany child node is an instance of either an Import node or an ImportFrom node, then we found a localimport.
Then, we just create and append the error.
Note that, every node has a line number and offset.So, we can just forward those on to our error.
Here we're using the line number and offset of eitherthe Import or ImportFrom statement.
After visiting all the function definitions, all the errors willbe stored in this list.
So, now all we need to do is call our visitor from our plugin.
Our plugin willcreate the visitor.
Then we'll start the visiting process and pass in the root of the ast.
Finally, weyield all the errors that the visitor had stored.
Running flake8 on the cool_module now correctlyshows us the error
that we aren't allowed to use a local import and it even gets the line and callnumber correct.
Okay, this works. We accomplished the goal.
But we wouldn't want to create many differentvisitors
if we had many different rules that we wanted to add to our linter.
Traversing the entireast is extremely expensive if you have a large codebase.
I would actually refactor this a littlebit in order to make it easier to add multiple checks
without traversing the tree multiple times.
So, what I did here was, I extracted basically the body of the check
that was actually doing thechecking to see if anything was wrong with the tree
and I extracted that into a check function.
I wrap it up in a class and put the message as a class attribute.
So, for every kind of new checkthat I want to write, I just make a new class, I give it a message and a check function.
I have thecheck function pass the list of errors that it's supposed to append to.
Then in our node visitor, Ijust call the check function of every check class that I want to run.
If you want to add options toyour plugin like adding a strict flag or something like that, you can also do that.
In your plugin,just create a @staticmethod add_options that takes an option_manager.
You can import the optionmanager like this.
If you've ever used argparse, then option manager will be very familiar to you.
It's basically a thin wrapper around argparse.
So, if I wanted to add some fancy variableas an option, then I would do it like this.
Specify the flag that you want. What's the typeof the variable?
What's the name of the variable? This is going to show up in the help text.
Giveit a default value.
This allows people to set it from their configuration file and specify anyhelp text.
At this point, if you run flake8 with --help, you'll see the documentation for your plugin.
We see the --some-fancy-variable, the name n and our description.
In order to get the values of anyspecified options, you need to add this parse_options function.
It's another @staticmethod andit takes an options parameter which is an actual argparse.Namespace.
Any variables you set willnow just be attributes of this options variable.
So, if you wanted to say enable strict mode orsomething based off of an option, you just set that as a flag here.
And this gets called beforethe run method gets called.
So, all of your options and whatever you set will be available before therun happens.
If you want to test your knowledge, here's some homework.
First problem: Write a pluginto warn against any use of eval.
Don't worry about sneaky cases. Just check for literal eval.
Nextproblem: Forbid the creation of any new metaclasses.
And lastly: Write a plugin that for multipleassignments forbids multiple uses of the same name.
This is a popular confusing example to throwaround. Let's forbid it.
The name a is used multiple times here and we don't want to allow that.
See myvideo if you'd like an explanation of how multiple assignment works.
And finally, if you're reallyserious about writing your own linting rules,
you should really package your linting code.
Rightnow, all of this code is just depending on all these files being in the same directory.
That'svery flaky.
For a real project, I would recommend packaging your custom rules, so that you canjust pip install them.
See my video on automated testing if you'd like to get up to speed onhow to package your projects.
As always, thank you for watching. And thank you to my patrons
and donors for supporting me.
See you next time.